the jurogan experience and the other
thing is i don't know if you're familiar
with this but
there's now a connection between quantum
computing
and black holes yeah what's that
connection
it's a weird one so it's all weird well
this is like
hyper this is like weird squared or
something but work over the last 20
years has established that
when you have a black hole actually even
more general systems but talk about a
black hole
there's an alternate description of a
black hole in terms of what's known as
the holographic
description it's as if there's a
two-dimensional world that surrounds any
given three-dimensional world
that has exactly the same physics as the
three-dimensional world that we're
familiar with
and yet it describes it in completely
different language
so a black hole gravity is obviously
essential that's how a black hole forms
but in this dictionary that physicists
have developed there's a description of
a black hole that doesn't involve
gravity
only involves quantum mechanics and the
beautiful thing is
the quantum processes in that quantum
world
mimic the kinds of processes that people
have been developing
for quantum computing quantum error
correction code
and there's a dictionary that people
have proposed for
that quantum language on the holographic
boundary
with physics in the interior and the
dictionary shows that the quantum error
correcting code
may be the reason why space time itself
holds together
so there's this bizarre way in which
everything that we know about in the
world around us
has a translated dictionary version in a
different world
that lacks gravity but has quantum
mechanics and so people are
using some of the insights from quantum
computing
to understand questions about black
holes in space time
so is that strange that's so strange so
as
quantum computing expands much like
as computing expands if you go back to
the early nasa computers and filled up a
whole room
we can extrapolate that as we get better
at this and you look 50 years
down the line from now quantum computing
will be the standard it would be the
norm
and it would probably radically alter
our understanding
of everything including black holes
including backgrounds that's right so
there's a real possibility
that the language that we use for
space-time in black holes
may bear a profound imprint of the
language that we are developing to
understand quantum
computing quantum computers i was just
reading some article about black holes
roaming through the universe and that
some of them
some of them they're detached from
galaxies right they can be i mean
oftentimes people think about black
holes as these gargantuan structures
that
form from collapsed stars there's a big
one in the center of our milky way
galaxy
weighs 4 million times out of the sun
the photograph
of a black hole in the galaxy m87 that
got the world excited a couple of years
back
55 million light years away billions of
times the mass of the sun but the
reality is
anything if you compress it enough
becomes
a black hole if you take an orange and
you squash an orange down sufficiently
small
according to einstein it becomes a black
hole so these things don't have to be
gargantuan the flip side of it is we
also
typically have an intuition that black
holes are really dense right that's
usually the way we think about them
but if you make something sufficiently
large regardless of how low its density
is it will also become a black hole so
you can make a black hole out of air
by just having enough air if you have
enough air sufficiently large sphere of
air it would become a black hole too
with the density of
air so all the intuitions that we
typically have about black holes that
they have to be dense
and they have to be gargantuan not right
so black holes are just a part of the
elemental structure of
reality itself yeah when you look at
einstein's equations
right in his mathematics there's a
little formula that you can see
where it says if you have any mass m
whatever mass you want
and you squeeze it into a radius r
that's less than
2 times newton's constant 2g times m
divided by
c squared speed of light squared a
formula details don't matter
but you take any mass if the radius
within which that mass sits is less than
2g m over c squared it is a black hole
period end of story
according to einstein now einstein left
out quantum mechanics
weirdly right because his nobel prize
was for quantum mechanics it was for a
paper he wrote in 1905 about the
photoelectric effect but he never
really believed that quantum mechanics
was the true description
of the world and when he was developing
the general theory of relativity he was
just thinking about gravity and not
quantum mechanics
stephen hawking came along in 1974 and
started to inject quantum mechanics into
our understanding of things like black
holes
and that's where hawking proved that
black holes are not completely black
he showed that black holes allow a
certain amount of radiation
to leak out of their surface leak out of
the event arrives and or leak out from
just beyond the edge of the event
horizon
and so yes when you think about black
holes
as far as we can tell they are a
fundamental quality of the world
but you have to include quantum physics
to truly understand them and that's the
cutting edge of what's happening right
now
so they're a fundamental quality of the
world but they're also in the center of
every galaxy
it seems to be the case the sloan
digital sky
survey did a wonderful study of
a vast number of galaxies and i've seen
these wonderful images where they put
like a little red circle
around all those galaxies that have a
black hole in their center and there are
red circles all over
that imagery so it seems to be a
ubiquitous quality
that black holes are at the center of
galaxies and those are
typically gargantuan black holes
millions or billions of times
the mass of the sun do we know why they
exist at the center of the galaxy
you know there's still a lot of
uncertainty about galactic
formation you know some have suggested
that
early stars which were quite large
compared to
more modern stars when they exhausted
their nuclear fuel
and they collapsed in on each other they
created black holes that were large
and then they continued to suck in more
material from the environment they grew
larger and larger still so that's
sort of one rough way that people think
about how these massive
enormous black holes may have formed but
it's uncertain
ligo you know this laser interferometer
gravitational wave
observatory gravitational waves it took
headlines a few years ago when it
detected the first ripples in the fabric
of space
it detected them from two black holes
that were 1.4 billion light years away
like 1.4 billion years ago
rotating around each other going near
the speed of light
slamming into each other creating a
tidal wave in the fabric of space
that rippled outward at the speed of
light part of it raced toward planet
earth
there wasn't anybody on planet earth to
see it at that moment but it had 1.4
billion year journey to
traverse a race toward planet earth when
it's
about a hundred thousand light years
away grazes the milky way galaxy
continues to race toward earth
when it's a hundred light years away a
guy named albert einstein writes down
equations that suggest there could be
these gravitational waves unknown that
one is already racing toward the planet
right
and it continues to race onward two
light days
it's two light days away when they turn
on the newly refined version of the
ligo detector and two days later that
wave rolls by planet earth
shakes the two detectors one in
louisiana there are washington state
giving us the first direct detection of
ripples in the fabric of space and
establishing that the story that i told
you is true
wow you know so so these things are real
they're out there that is wild and and
before the direct
radio telescopic imagery from the event
horizon telescope of the black hole in
m87
that rip on the fabric of space was the
most direct evidence that black holes
are real because
when you took the way that the machine
in louisiana and washington it twitched
for just you know a tiny fraction of a
second when you figured out
using supercomputers what the cause of
the wave must have been you are led
to two black holes that are 28 and 31
times
the mass of the sun or 36 times the mass
of sun numbers of that sort
and that was the only explanation for
the data and so there's this beautiful
indirect proof that these stellar-sized
black holes
are actually out there and then of
course we take a photograph of one
in a nearby galaxy so do we know why
black holes would collide with each
other are they attracted to each other
because of their math it's a good
question
yeah so certainly that is part of it so
binary star systems are not uncommon
they're fairly common where two stars
will be orbiting around each other if
those two stars
exhaust their nuclear fuel they can each
collapse to a black hole so that's one
possibility or it could be
a black hole's wandering through and
captures another
black hole it's a possibility too i mean
i think
go ahead and ask you a question but
there's one point i want to make as well
which is wasn't that
good please yeah well it was just that
many people have in mind that black
holes sort of reach out and grab
everything in yeah but a black hole of
mass m
a black hole whose mass is the same as
the sun has the same gravitational pull
as the sun
it's not it doesn't pull any harder than
the sun
it's just that you can get closer to it
because it's so small
and therefore you can experience the
gravity more strongly
but you know a brick of mass m and a
black hole of mass m they exert the same
gravitational pull
okay so we have this misconception that
black holes are always
these super massive objects that have
incredible amounts of gravity
and they're sucking in planets and stars
and churning them up
because we're thinking of massive black
holes like the supermassive black holes
are at the center of the galaxy
which is like what one half of one
percent of the mass of the galaxy
well let's see so if if our galaxy has
say uh a hundred billion suns you know
and that guy is about four million times
the mass of the sun yes you're talking
about
you know a thousandth or something of
that sort isn't that crazy when you say
that a hundred billion
suns and you have to wrap your head
around the idea of a hundred billion
stars and that's and that's just our
little puny little galaxy that's a thing
that creates at least 100 billion
galaxies at least and this is just
in the observable universe i mean do you
know if you take your thumb
and you put your thumb on a nice clear
night and you block out
a thumbnail worth of the sky you're
blocking out about 10 million galaxies
it's so crazy it's so crazy because
those numbers i i hear you say those
numbers i can repeat those numbers
but i don't think i'm really
internalizing them because they're so
non-human scale right we've just never
experienced anything
like that at all and it could be that
it's infinite
space could go on infinitely far it
could be that the galaxies continue
onward infinitely far
and therefore the numbers we're talking
about could be minuscule
on the scale of the fullness of reality
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes you just need
to search for the jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience